this is where it all began authorities
believe the outbreak of the corona virus
can be traced back to a seafood market
in Wuhan it shudders have now come down
and the city has followed suit a stop
Thursday morning the city has been cut
off from the rest of the country
trains flights buses and ferries have
been cancelled even public transport
within Wuhan has ground to a halt
hospital wards have had to deal with
hundreds of cases but so far the World
Health Organization has refrained from
declaring a global health emergency much
depends on whether the measures set in
place by the Chinese government will
prove effective trying to contain a city
of 11 million people is new to to
science it has not been tried before as
a public health measure so we cannot at
this stage say it will or it will not
work with the city sealed off from the
outside world view headed to the
epicenter of the outbreak
the last trains bound for Wuhan were
unusually empty
and there's plenty of elbow room for
passengers on the final flights into the
city
some fear repeat of the deadly outbreak
of the SARS virus which killed over 800
people in 2003 I'm really worried
I'm really scared it'll become the next
stars that's why we all wear masks
others are less concerned who hon is a
city of 11 million people just about 400
have been infected that's a very low
percentage and the fatalities are all
old people all over China people are on
the move to visit relatives over the
Lunar New Year holidays it's one of the
biggest annual movements of people in
the world
despite the lockdown of Wuhan it's
likely that somewhere the corona virus
is travelling among tho well for the
very latest let's cross over to our
correspondent Fabien Kuchma in Beijing
Fabien the city of Wuhan is at the
center of this outbreak tell us more
about what authorities are doing there
to contain the virus already yesterday
and the authorities have issued a travel
warning people not to travel to Wuhan
and also not to leave the city and now
of course the city is in lockdown it's
isolated that's a pretty radical
decision and just have to look it's 11
million people living there and also
from the space I mean it's basically
like putting a greater London area under
lockdown but from a medical point of
view this is understandable because all
the confirmed virus cases they originate
from a fish market in Wuhan and they
have been spread by citizens from who
Mohan who then travel also to Thailand
to South Korea to Japan and so of course
authorities are focusing on that area
but even in Beijing where I am based
right now you see a lot of you know body
temperature scanners especially at
airports and also the train stations and
yeah people are also very cautious well
there are concerns that this virus has
spread more widely in China infected
more people than officially claimed you
say people are cautious how
worried are they across the country they
were very worried I wouldn't call it a
panic but you know literally everyone is
wearing face masks by far the large
majority to protect themselves and
people are very skeptical towards the
you know government numbers and also to
the official state news and I think it's
safe to assume that the numbers are much
higher that's also you know in a line
with estimates from scientists from the
Imperial College of London or the City
University of Hong Kong they assume that
far more have been affected and the
reason is many people here they still
remember the SAS pandemic in 2002 and
2003 and at that time the authorities
tried to cover up the real threat of the
virus so what earth can authorities do
now that they aren't already doing to
make sure that this doesn't get any
worse well I mean the isolation of Wuhan
is already a pretty radical step also if
you consider that the virus outbreak is
still at an early stage I would say that
actually the authorities take a
different step compared to what they did
and bring the SAS pandemic they are more
transparent I mean they are reporting
and now more prominently about the virus
outbreak as a party permission from the
Communist Party has also urged its
politicians to not cover up any
infections and not to you know just for
the reputation of local politicians to
you know downplay the threat they caught
for more transparency and I think that's
it's a big sign and a big ending
indication that they take it much more
seriously and they don't want to repeat
the same mistakes that they did in 2002
and 2003
fabien thank you very much for bringing
yourself to date there for correspond
party encroachment in Beijing